[spaceship engines roar]
- WAIT, WAIT.
WE GOT TO BE CAREFUL HERE.
THIS PLACE IS CRAWLING
WITH THEM.
WHAT WAS THAT?
- WHAT?
- COVER ME.
- GUYS! HEY, GUYS!
HEY, GUYS.
OH, THANK GOD.
HEY, WE STARTED
A COMMUNITY OF SURVIVORS.
Y'ALL COME LIVE WITH US.
- WAIT.
HOW DID YOU KNOW?
- COME ON.
REDNECK WANTS US TO MOVE
INTO HIS COMMUNITY?
US?
LET'S GO.
- GUYS, OVER HERE!
OH, THANK GOD THERE ARE OTHERS!
- WOULD YOU LET
ME DATE YOUR DAUGHTER?
- OF COURSE!
- OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
AAH!
PLEASE DON'T HURT ME!
MY BEST FRIEND IS BLACK
AND I LOVE JAY-Z,
AND MY FAVORITE MOVIE
IS THINK LIKE A MAN.
- SHE'S GOOD.
- COME WITH US.
- OKAY.
- STAY CLOSE.
- WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
- EMILY.
both: OF COURSE IT IS.
[tense dubstep music]
♪
- HEY, HEY, HEY!
DON'T SHOOT!
- WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THE POLICE?
- WELL,
I LOVE THEIR THIRD ALBUM.
- AAH! AAH!
[stammers]
I DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY!
NO MONEY!
[screaming]
[continues screaming]
- OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
THANK GOD YOU GUYS SHOWED UP.
I GOT TO GET OUT OF HERE.
IT'S A SILVER LEXUS.
JUST PULL IT RIGHT UP FRONT,
AND DON'T SCUFF THE PAINT,
ALL RIGHT?
I JUST HAD IT BUFFED.
- WAS HE AN ALIEN, TOO?
- YEP.